The Joe Rogan Experience how was Logan
Paul as a wrestler dude it was I'm sure
he's great yeah he's gonna be a wrestler
oh he should be he's like he's a star
he's a star his podcast is actually
really good yeah really The Dana White
I'm trying to get on it or something
well no The Dana White episode I listen
to the whole thing I listened to a clip
he gets in on yeah and it's great it's
an amazing Pod episode
he's done a lot of [ __ ] man I mean you
got to give the guys props he's not lazy
he fought Floyd Mayweather in a boxing
match I don't care if he's 50 pounds
heavier than before I mean it's still
Floyd [ __ ] amazing yeah that's crazy
look at that yeah dude he was doing
splits and [ __ ] that's pretty impressive
yeah
I had no idea he was that flexible
that's crazy
wow hey good for him you ever see Delia
break up with him
makeup yeah because the humidity used to
go at it and he's like hey whatever I
said before the guy's a star forget it
oh wow wow what did Julia used to say
about him he's just like [ __ ] this idiot
[ __ ] this kid who's like a influencer
yeah that was easy to do though I was
wrong this guy's awesome him and his
brother are [ __ ] animals I mean what
they've been able to do is incredible
his brother knocked out Tyron Woodley
with one punch that's crazy
he's like a vicious vicious Striker not
a wrestler he's a striker well he was a
wrestler
but but the fact that he knocked out one
of the greatest welterweight champions
of all time with one punch is [ __ ]
Bonkers
watch this watch this oh I did see that
okay Jake
[Music]
face playing with dude wipes in your
butt see he's got the power out of the
two of them like Logan Logan is a really
good athlete but he's not as good of a
boxer but Jake Paul on top of being a
better boxer he's got like legit power
Tyran took it on like just a few weeks
notice and there's no way he was
conditioned for that fight so when
you're not like fully Camp conditioned
you take breaks like and you're in the
fight like there's times where you maybe
should move and you go I just gotta take
a [ __ ] break here and you're like
trying to like gather up your energy and
you manage it over the course of the
three minutes you can't just go out like
when you see like if you see a fighter
like Manny Pacquiao when he's in his
prime and he's [ __ ] supremely
conditioned there's no thought about
conserving energy man is just thinking
about how to [ __ ] you up just thinking
about how to [ __ ] you up because his
conditioning is off the charts I mean
he's not going he's not sprinting he's
conserving some energy but that's not
his primary concern his primary concern
is just like hitting you when a guy gets
to a point where you know most likely
he's not training every day hard when he
doesn't have a fight scheduled then he
gets a fight scheduled and it's only two
weeks notice you can kind of get in
shape in two weeks but not not like the
kind of shape you need to be able to
yeah so he looked he was taking a break
because he also must have thought like
it's not an MMA guy it's a Paul he
already fought him
but there were moments in that first
fight where he's pulling and Tyrone
would turn it on he was he the better it
would have been a different fight if
Tyron had the time to prepare I
guarantee you a guarantee you because he
would have had more conditioning more
confidence to hit the gas like when you
don't have condition if you don't have a
full Camp you you still are in shape
you're a [ __ ] professional athlete
he's still a [ __ ] stud of a man but
he doesn't have the the kind of
conditioning that you need to go a hard
fight when you you know you you
condition your body three minutes three
minutes hard work one minute rest three
minutes hard work one minute rest world
work Plyometrics you get conditioned
he's not there's no way he was
conditioned yeah but that's part of
their attack is I think people
underestimate and that's how they kind
of yeah
everybody the wrestler guy the real
wrestler whatever his name was we got
knocked out
yeah all these guys like whatever you're
not saying he's like you guys are
actually working hard I actually I
actually think aspirin didn't give a
[ __ ] right I actually yeah
dude and then listen asking how to hip
replacement he took the fight after hip
replacement and not that long after hip
replacement there's no way he was in
shape for that fight and ask him I don't
got paid he lost and he was like so oh
yeah
and he's funny yeah he is funny did
Tyrone really make more in those two
fights than his whole UFC career
supposedly most likely wow wow yeah I
don't know what the number is wow see I
like those Paul because it's kind of
like the YouTube comics they offered he
offered Chris Rock and Will Smith 40
million dollars Paul Jake Paul did Chris
Brown I don't have any I don't care
about Wilson well not well even if he
did first of August it's very small it's
not fair right the difference is like 60
pounds he never trained to play the
greatest boxer of all time right yeah
Will Smith put up will Smith as Muhammad
Ali dude Wilson is a [ __ ] athlete
because he when he was playing Muhammad
Ali it was one of those rare moments
this is like um a few guys that have
pulled it off Daniel Day-Lewis did a
grade in the boxer
um
Mark Wahlberg did a grade of the fighter
when he played uh Mickey Ward he's got a
fantastic job but show the video of him
moving around because there's video from
the fight and he was [ __ ] good man
that's crazy that picture of him taking
the robe off literally he got like the
kind of still baby fat but Jack like Ali
exactly like Ali he did a fantastic job
as Ali and that's him against Sonny
Liston
cinematography yeah but he's a good
athlete man I think it's a Michael
that's why this is so nice Fair like
this is this to have a boxing match
between this man and Chris Rock is crazy
yeah